hi there steve kaufman here um
you may know that i was in france for
10 days
and i want to talk a little bit about
happiness and language learning because
these are thoughts that came to me as a
result of some of the reading that i did
while i was in france
so
um i read this book here
which is a book about francois promise
it's called francois
talks about the renaissance period in
france the life of france
who was a very
romantic and
war-like
king and i'm only
a third of the way through the book at
this point so i have lots to learn but
it's of course very enjoyable to read
about that period of france having
visited some of the chateau along the la
he was responsible i think for building
chambo and bill you know adding to some
of the others i think he was responsible
for
making um
the louvre or at least the chateau in in
paris the chateau du louvre
what it is today
so
that's fun that's happiness reading
in this case in a foreign language about
the history of the country that you're
visiting
but getting on further along on the
subject of happiness i also picked up
this book i went to my old school at
chiang spo sounds pretty teak i went to
their bookstore and there was this
little book
le conomie du bonner the economics of
happiness so i read through that it was
very interesting and it made reference
to a number of people who wrote about
happiness and
uh measuring happiness and the attempt
now to measure you know happiness rather
than just measuring the gnp of countries
and
and so forth and the name that came up
quite often in his book was that of
daniel kahneman
who is the winner of a nobel prize
and so when i was in london i bought
this book
which is called thinking fast and slow
and that is a very very interesting book
uh i very much uh suggest that you read
it
uh it's uh it's not exciting it's not
fun to read like
francois pomier
and i'm not sure i fully understand it
but
what it says
from what i can tell is that we have
sort of two
ways of thinking
the fast way and the slow way the fast
way is our intuitive way of thinking
it's uh
very much influenced by
um
our experience
i guess
patterns that we've built up in our
uh prejudices perhaps
we jump to conclusions and he
demonstrates just how irrational so much
of our thinking is
um
you know you'd have to read the book to
see all the different examples we're
very much influenced by
um
you know if we describe someone as being
energetic enthusiastic and stubborn
we have a better impression of that
person than if you know if we say
energetic enthusiastic stubborn
and envious
we may still think that person's a good
person because we started out with
positive terms if we turn it around and
we begin with envious and stubborn then
the enthusiastic and energetic uh
doesn't seem to overcome those first
attributes that we gave the person
that's just one example that comes from
from memory there are a number of others
and that our tendency is to want to use
the the easy way of thinking what he
calls cognitive ease
we want if we're asked a complicated
question we'll substitute that for a
simple question that we can easily
answer because that is our quick
thinking our slow thinking is more
complicated it's furrowed brow it's it's
trying to make complicated calculations
and and if if we are driving a car if
we're multitasking it's very easy to
combine the sort of easy thinking tasks
uh with some other activity however if
we have to calculate you know 37 by 43
we can't make that calculation in our
head while driving a car for example
anything that we are already prepared
conditioned to respond to
those easy cognitive things we can do
those while we're driving a car
and he talks also about how um you know
typically
uh people are far too overconfident
about how
uh
you know their ability to achieve
projects uh you know
deliver any major project on on budget
and on time and all of these things
because we're always optimistic we're
always overconfident we don't really
analyze all of the facts at hand
we tend to be carried away with
the sort of
prejudices that we have going in and our
our desire to succeed and our
overconfidence and so forth so it's
quite an interesting book and i mean i
don't do it justice here and i have to
read it again to fully understand it
but
he also talks about happiness and how
for example we have a tendency to
place greater emphasis on the peaks of
happiness or suffering rather than the
duration
so we are
we tend to forget you know that we were
in pain for you know 10 minutes but the
peaks were low whereas if we had very
high level of pain for a very short
period of time that's worth
worse and the same is true in reverse we
tend to remember the sort of peaks of
enjoyment rather than the longer period
of happiness and so he questions to some
extent
uh all these different evaluations of
happiness and how value how how you know
valid they are
uh and so forth but what i take out of
all of this is the following
first of all insofar as language
learning is concerned
the more i can do with my quick learning
pre you know pre-prepared you know um
patterns that are already created in my
mind easy cognitive the more things that
i do that way the better off i am the
more i enjoy my language learning
we had someone at our forum at link come
on and say you know the
because that link we cache every time
one of our users goes to a dictionary
whichever dictionary and and selects a
meaning for a word from you know spanish
into english that's cached in the system
not all of those hints are necessarily
appropriate and they don't provide you
information on the tense or the
conjugations and so forth so someone's
saying this is not valid we need to have
all the conjugations there we need to
have this that and the other and i say
well not for me because
really i just want to focus on the
content that i'm reading and listening
to so i get a suggestion of roughly what
the word means and i try to piece it
together from the context and that's
really all i want i don't want to bother
myself with all the
you know conjugations and stuff because
half i know from experience that i tend
to forget that stuff pretty pretty
quickly so i'd rather just focus on the
easy cognitive things
okay yeah it roughly means that so
therefore in this context it seems to
mean this so i kind of am getting some
sense out of the context without having
to think about it too much if i listen
to it i can listen to it while i'm doing
the dishes i don't have to
focus on trying to remember anything
it's just easy cognitive stuff and when
i'm speaking the language i just go to
that
easy cognitive whatever reflex i have
built up in there be it right be it
wrong that's what i go with i don't
worry too much about trying to remember
the rules is this correct or not correct
and i find that that this sort of if we
can develop
our little our knowledge of the language
uh
again through ma as crash and says
through massive listening and reading we
develop these
these patterns we develop these sort of
intuitive reactions
some of which are right some of which
are wrong and and uh
kahneman and his book makes the point
that a lot of our intuitive
uh views on things are are
false or wrong or distorted it doesn't
matter we need these we operate on the
basis of these intuitive reactions these
this
quick thinking that we have and i think
the same is true of language we need to
develop that side of it
personally the more i rely on
the uh slow think work it through
analyze and stuff the less enjoyment i
have in my language learning and i think
the less well i speak
uh
so and and so that's one thing that
comes out of it the other thing that he
mentions is that uh
you know when we look at what makes us
happy
one of the things is the ability to
focus
on the moment that we are in
we can't be happy if we're studying
french and we think we should be
studying korean
we have to totally savor the moment
savor the language that we are studying
or if we would rather be
you know out dancing then we should be
out dancing uh so that the idea that you
you savor the moment that you're in
is is important to uh
to achieving happiness and i think the
same is true in language learning that
you have to
you know
basically commit yourself to the task at
hand and enjoy the task at hand derive
pleasure from the task at hand rather
than
thinking that you're doing something
that's gonna you know
bring you some benefits later on so it's
unpleasant and it's hard work and you're
struggling and stuff but you're hoping
that somehow that this is going to
uh
get you to where you want to be
i found that
if the approach to language learning is
this is fun i'm enjoying listening to
whatever it is i'm enjoying reading it
i'm joined being in the language in the
moment that that's really all you need
to do without thinking of where it's
going to lead to
and and then when you do occasionally
have that sense that you've made a major
step forward which we
every so often feel even though for for
long periods of time we think we're not
improving then there are moments when
you think you do then you should really
savor those
uh moments without worrying about the
mistakes that you made
without worrying about
um
whether you can remember you know
endings of verbs and stuff none of that
really matters
so
um i guess
really i i i it may not be very clear
and i think i have to go back in to read
the book again and i would be very happy
to discuss this with some of you who may
choose to read the book again i'll show
you the book here
uh
thinking fast and slow daniel kahneman
but i think there's a lot in there that
i have to go back and read again and
again
uh which demonstrates just how faulty a
lot of our thinking is but but that's
the way we are the other big thing in
canaan is his emphasis on
on luck any in any success
luck has a major role to play and
therefore if we have a a string of
success there's every likelihood that
this will be followed by a string of
failures or vice versa because
because luck is such a big factor there
is this effect of what he calls the
regression to the mean
so that
inevitably statistically if you've had a
lot of success through luck you're going
to have some periods of less success and
so we we need to accept that as well
but there's a lot of lessons to life in
that book it's time seems a bit cut and
dried statistical analysis
prospect theory uh you know uh decision
making theory and stuff like that
but i think there's a lot there that's
that's valid in general and in
particular valid for
for language learning so
it's kind of a bit of a fuzzy
rant today but i think there is
something there
uh
at least in in my own experience
and those people who like to get into
the nitty-gritty of grammar and enjoy
doing that and that's their thing
they're in the flow they're enjoying it
by all means go for it
but i think a lot of people don't
and even if you don't there are so many
ways that you can enjoy language
learning
where you're not worried about where you
stand vis-a-vis other people you're not
worried about where you stand vis-a-vis
some future goal you have you're just
enjoying being in the moment you're
enjoying
this sort of
cognitive ease of just listening and
reading
in the knowledge that in fact it's
building up a lot of experience
in your brain a lot of patterns that
eventually will become intuition some
may be wrong some may be right but you
can flow with that intuition and you're
building up an ability to react easily
quickly
and even in a way that you can multitask
in the language
and that that's happiness in language
learning and it's not more complicated
than that and you don't have to worry
about whether you're a b1 b2 c1 toeic
toefl and all the rest of it that will
all come of its own
if you can
sort of um
just invest of yourself
in into the language in this in this
sort of natural learning process so i'm
not sure any of this makes sense but
there you go i look forward to your
comments
bye for now